[Music]
all right uh for our cancellation today
we turn our attention to a gender
studies master's thesis composed by a
student at the university of wisconsin
milwaukee
jonathan k is an editor at quillette and
he first brought attention to this on
his twitter page
the document had been available on the
university's website but has since been
put under embargo whatever that's
supposed to mean what it actually means
is that the university is embarrassed
that the public took note of this and so
they took it out of the public viewing
for that reason
all i really need to do is read the
first part of the introduction to this
thesis no other commentary is necessary
though i will offer some anyway so here
it is it's a little lengthy but it's
worth your time so
sit back and enjoy here it is
and this is all totally real by the way
i assure you
as a white first generation college
graduate who attended a mid-sized
private university my identities and
experiences inspired this study
my whiteness offers a level of inherent
violence to this study because of the
history of privilege and structural and
overt acts of harm my ancestors have
contributed to society this echoes my
experience in identifying as an
anti-racist racist who as a white person
spelled with an x instead of an o a per
sixth
who as a white person
is inherently racist but applies and is
accountable to anti-racism in my life
through activist educator and researcher
capacities
white supremacy is frequently
misunderstood as only pertaining to
overt or explicit acts of violence like
neo-nazis or the ku klux klan however
white supremacy in the context of this
study centers the relationship between
historical and unconscious bias that
benefits whiteness through its
structures policies culture and
experiences over non-white individuals
therefore it is irresponsible for me to
be to begin this study without
acknowledging the privileges that i am
afforded in conducting this study as a
white individual but also the
contribution that i make to violence
like white supremacy in the academy
violence and university shows up in
different ways than what may be
explicitly produced violence in the
context of this study includes
interpersonal violence like slurs and
ignorance politics that
disproportionately have a negative
impact on marginalized identities or
bodies
the hierarchical misuse of
administrative power
that make change seem impossible and the
lack of understanding and support given
to the marginalized university community
and that's just the first few sentences
of the introduction
it's good that they took the whole
document off the website i don't know if
you could read much more of that or hear
much more of it without slipping
irretrievably into insanity
you know i have many titles theocratic
fascist philanthropist virginia resident
now i've added children's author to that
but um i think the one thing that i was
missing
is lord you know that's that's what you
need in front of your of your name and i
now am officially lord matt walsh
through established titles this is my
this is my official plaque here
affirming that i am lord matt walsh that
is my legal name established titles is
your opportunity to earn the title of
lord or lady and gain the respect that
you deserve and certainly crave i know
that i do all you need is a one square
foot plot of land in scotland that's all
you need
and established titles is a project
based on historic scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lairds or
lords and ladies in english
in your title pack you'll receive at
least one square foot of dedicated land
on a private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number which uh with which you can see
the exact location of your land with
this certificate you could officially
change your name to lord or lady and get
it on your credit card plane tickets etc
established title is having a great
limited time sale so go to
establishtitles.com matt walsh to save
10 off today and remember to use
discount code matt walsh or just click
the link below that's established dot
com matt walsh or just click the link
below so let's go through this somewhat
haphazardly and make
four points in no particular order
first
bookmark this podcast and remember that
segment and come back to it this segment
in fact that we're in right now and come
back to it next time somebody demands
that you define critical race theory
because what you just heard
is critical race theory it's hard to
define because it's a jumbled
unintelligible mess
it's like being asked to describe in
precise terms
the contents of a porta
now you may not be able to break it all
down in specific detail but what you can
say is that whatever is in there it's a
whole bunch of
for critical race theory the particulars
are intentionally hard to discern and
also irrelevant whatever finer
distinction it draws we know that it
teaches that white people are inherently
racist
that all non-white people are victims of
systemic racism that all white people
are beneficiaries of systemic privilege
and that white people all bear guilt
because of this and that also because of
this they cannot be the victims of
racism
even if a black man beats a white man
unconscious and spits on his lifeless
body still that is not racism and
arguably it's not even violence
nothing can be racism against the white
man that's what crt teaches as we just
heard
second
notice how
will
and agency are removed from the equation
according to the crt vision of life all
of the fault lies with systems and
institutions and policies and the past
whites inherit their guilt uh this way
and non-whites inherit their
victimization in the same way
nobody does anything
nobody's responsible for anything
we're all helpless dried up little
leaves floating on the wind
the author even says that ignorance is
violence
meaning that you can be guilty of
violence simply for not knowing
something
no willful action is taken on your part
you simply did not encounter certain
information and that makes you violent
again there's no agency there's no
choice there's no will
third
we see that crt and leftism as a whole
um are a religion
but of course religion isn't bad in and
of itself so i'm always kind of uh
uncomfortable using religion in this
kind of pejorative way oh it's just a
religion
i have a religion i'm religious
the problem isn't that it's a religion
the problem is that it's a false
religion
and you could tell a false religion
because almost everything it says can
only be understood within the context of
itself
everything is insular right in in a
false religion
um or in a cult like scientology or
something
it has no insight or wisdom to offer
people who do not subscribe to it you
have to be a believer to see the value
or even meaning in any of this so it's
as i said it's like scientology you know
they they they indoctrinate you into it
little by little and there are a lot of
reasons for that one of the reasons is
that if you just dove into scientology
and they put you all the way up at level
seven or whatever the levels are and
they put you there right away
nothing that you're hearing would make
any sense to you
because you have to be brought into it
slowly and slowly until you kind of
adopt the logic which is an illogic of
this whole system
but from the outside it's completely
ridiculous and has nothing of value to
offer anybody
um christianity which is not a false
religion is not like that christianity
has
um
has wisdom you know even if you're not
religious even if you don't believe in
christianity you can and many people
have pick up pick up the gospels and
read them and you'll find
much wisdom and insight into the human
condition that you don't need to be a
christian to understand or even believe
so that's the difference
and finally i think i said there were
four things so the fourth thing is that
uh this is what you get at college okay
i don't need to elaborate on that very
much i have many times in the past this
is college so if you if you're a parent
and you're thinking about sending your
kid to college and plunging yourself or
your child into decades of debt
this is what you're paying for to turn
your kid into that
and that is why we must say the person
who wrote that thesis is canceled and
gender studies programs are canceled and
the university of wisconsin milwaukee is
cancelled
and uh really the whole university
system i think in the end is cancelled
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends